cares what people think you know
everybody has a different opinion you're
not out here to make friends you're out
here to make money these people can
write about whatever they want but
they're marks and you know what a mark
is the journal these are supposed to be
journalists but they're letting their
opinions and their feelings get in the
way of the way they're writing an
article yeah that's not real journalism
that's not how you would do it no I
don't care what those people think I'm
going to keep doing me and being me and
if people have a problem with me come
see me in octagon but there's not a man
alive that can stop me right now